[Music]
just
north of the martian equator lies
a 45 kilometer wide impact crater
that scientists believe may have been
the site
of an ancient lake here at
gizero crater scientists theorized that
its frozen soil may contain the most
significant discovery of humankind
life on february 18
2021 nasa's perseverance rover started
searching this crater to find out if
we're truly alone
what is the likelihood of life on mars
what would these martians look like
and how will we send samples
back to earth this is what if
and here's what would happen if we
discovered life
on mars as
scientific american puts it it would
take a near
miracle for mars to be sterile
astrobiologist chris mckay at nasa
believes that earth and mars have been
sharing materials
for billions of years kind of like using
your roommate's spice rack
what i thought you said it was communal
[Music]
comets or
large meteorites that have hit earth may
have also
sent debris onto mars a tiny fraction of
this debris on mars
could have carried the same microbes
that kick-started
life as we know it on earth but
what would this alien life look like
many scientists agree that whatever life
on mars we might find
would need to be incredibly robust
with the combination of radiation and
freezing temperatures on mars
could any life form survive such a harsh
environment
as far-fetched as it sounds
microbiologists have discovered many
organisms that
thrive in extreme environments the
tardigrade or
water bear is a highly resistant
extremophile
it can withstand heat cold pressure
radiation and even a complete lack of
oxygen
there are also certain types of bacteria
on earth
that rapidly produce spores when faced
with hazardous conditions
the bacteria can then hibernate during
an extended period of drought and
withstand intense ionizing radiation
a team of 1 000 geologists chemists
physicists and biologists worldwide
have drilled 4.8 kilometers into the
earth and
discovered robust life forms mars
has a similar geological past to earth
so looking underground could be a great
place to start
by drilling into the gizero crater we
could encounter spores associated with a
relatively recent
geological era and on future missions to
mars
we may dig deeper and uncover fully
vegetative microbes
to find rock samples that might support
life
nasa's perseverance rover uses an array
of lasers
called a supercam it can study the
surface of mars
at a distance one of the lasers will
heat a rock sample
and vaporize it this creates a plasma
that can be
analyzed to understand its elemental
composition
another laser will reveal which
compounds
are in the dirt if the supercam detects
organic molecules or elevated
concentrations of elements like
nitrogen or phosphorus the rover will
head over to take a closer look it will
then
scan the soil in greater detail to
detect
any organic material hiding in the dirt
nasa's team on earth has only one shot
at
picking the right spot to gather these
samples
with limited space on board the rover
only a few dozen samples can be
collected so
no pressure and fingers crossed
if all goes well nasa plans to bring
back samples known for
preserving biosignatures on earth
biosignatures
are faint molecular traces left behind
by
microbes billions of years ago once the
samples are collected
nasa and the european space agency
plan two missions to get them back to
earth
this involves blasting tubes of rock and
soil samples
into orbit to be collected by another
spacecraft and then
return to earth whoa this looks kind of
fun
if perseverance's mission is successful
the discovery of life on mars
would be as groundbreaking as the
discovery of dna
in 1543 copernicus
boldly shook the status quo with his
theory that the planets
orbited the sun his discoveries
completely changed our world view no
longer putting earth at the center of
the universe
discovering life beyond earth could be
just as powerful
but not finding any life could raise
more questions
is the earth truly special are we alone
out here
even if we don't discover life these
martian rock samples will allow chemists
to study the geochemistry
mineralogy and foundational bedrock
materials of mars
in detail this could provide us with
essential insights into the climate
history of mars and
help us better understand earth's
climate as well
speaking of better understanding have
you ever struggled to find the right
words in an
email if you're watching what if videos
to sound smarter and impress your
friends
let grammarly help you express your
nerdy science facts with ease
here at under known i'm always sending
messages back and forth with the team
and my family and sometimes they can be
taken the wrong
way no no i didn't mean let's eat the
boss
i meant let's eat boss yeah i know i
forgot the comma
[Music]
with grammarly premium you can avoid any
future embarrassing moments like those
with
real time feedback and insights
grammarly will help
elevate your writing through tone word
choice
clarity and more and if you're a little
too verbose like me well
grammarly premium offers clarity and
vocabulary suggestions
to keep your sentences clear and concise
with grammarly premium
you can write like a pro with advanced
real-time feedback
it's the perfect writing tool for anyone
who wants to stand out with every word
and grammarly supports several platforms
with their desktop editor
browser plugin and mobile apps grammarly
doesn't just correct your mistakes it
helps you build up your skills as a
writer
elevate your writing with twenty percent
off grammarly premium by signing up at
grammarly.com
slash what if that's twenty percent off
grammarly premium
at g r a m m a r
l y dot com slash what if
in 1976 two viking landers became the
first spacecrafts from earth
to touch down on mars they too probed
for life in the martian soil and
the results are still debated to this
day
one experiment indicated that the
martian soil
tested positive for metabolism
on earth this would almost certainly
suggest the presence of life
but another related experiment found no
trace of organic material
whatsoever while most scientists have
not reconciled the conflicting results
the consensus is that there's no
conclusive evidence of life on mars
but several researchers disagree
recent discoveries of terrestrial
microorganisms
surviving outside of the iss indicate
that
life may be resilient enough for mars
and methane in the martian atmosphere
could be a sign of microbial methanogens
a type of microorganism that produces a
significant amount of methane
stinky aliens mind you it's possible
that
life on mars didn't have the right
conditions to start at all
or maybe it died off from an extinction
event
similar to the asteroid that wiped out
the dinosaurs
or it's even possible that we might end
up
finding life that was accidentally
brought to mars by
one of our many rovers let's hope this
perseverance mission
doesn't turn into a 2.7 billion dollar
face
palm if mars is your bag well
have you ever thought about setting up
shop there with recent developments in
rocketry
colonizing mars might be possible in our
lifetime
you better strap in because that's a
story
for another what if
you